all right finally uh from daily wire
outspoken leftist author Stephen King
blamed the box office failure of the
Marvels on woman hating Fanboys plus the
social media followers aren't letting
him get away with it um Stephen King
said some of the rejection of the
marbles maybe ad Marvel that is marbles
some of the rejection of the Marvels
maybe adolescent Fanboy hate you know
yuck
girls um that's what he said this was
after Marvel's was a massive
disappointment for the MCU pulling in
just $47 million during its opening
weekend the lowest in the franchises
history um but what's funny is that
there's a few things funny about this
but but King Stephen King earlier the
same day had tweeted this I don't go to
MCU movies don't care for them but I
find this barely masked gloating over
the low box office for the Marvels very
unpleasant why gloat over failure so
he's sure that the only reason people
don't like it is because they're sexist
but he hasn't even seen the movie and
isn't interested in seeing it
himself um as far as why people are
gloating over the failure I Steve and I
will answer that for you we're gloating
well I'm gloating I can only answer I
only speak for myself but uh I'm
gloating because the Marvels represents
everything that is terrible about modern
films everything that is destroying
modern films and it's bad that modern
films are being destroyed because film
is an important and Powerful art form it
really matters but it's being
cannibalized by the Marvels and all and
all the stuff like it and specifically
the Marvels is first of of course a
lifeless cash grab superhero movie that
does not
exist for any reason other than making
money we talked about this last week you
know it's you you know that I'm not a
superhero fan um but this is the point
like this is the central criticism that
I have of these kinds of because I you
know I know there are plenty people that
don't like the Marvels but they like
superhero movies in general and so they
don't like it when I criticize it
but you know these films and it's not
just superhero movies it's like all
these franchise film Star Wars all the
rest of all this
stuff they exist only to make money and
and yes every movie has people financing
it and producing it who are perhaps
mainly or even solely concerned about
the money so every movie is supposed to
make money every every movie has people
involved at some level who only care
about the money of course that is true
but traditionally you have people the
people who are most connected to the
film like the actual
um filmmakers and actors who also want
to make money but but before that they
want to tell a story they're they're
making the movie because they are saying
to the audience we've got this great
story we want to tell you and there's
still some
filmmakers out there like this you know
someone like uh uh Paul Thomas Anderson
or filmmaker like that real filmmaker a
a brilliant genius filmmaker who makes a
movie cuz he's saying like I've got a
story
I want to tell you and so and it's an
important story to me and so I'm going
to tell you the story gather around kids
gather around the campfire I'm going to
tell you a story
well these superhero movies don't have
anyone involved at any level who
actually wants to tell the story or
cares about the story literally every
single person at every level from the
actors and directors and producers all
the way up to uh people running the the
film the uh you know production
companies
everyone involv they're just doing
they're only doing it for the money they
don't care about the story the story is
like basically non-existent they're
exploiting a brand they're not telling a
story at all you know there's a lot at
stake this November so don't be chicken
and shop at the grocery store like usual
instead head over to good ranchers where
they have great meat puns but even
better uh they actually have great meat
too the puns are great but the meat is
even better don't miss their Black
Friday your way sale now live this
November get your favorite meat free for
an entire year that's right one year a
free steak salmon chicken or bacon when
you subscribe to any box right now
better yet when you subscribe to any box
on goodranchers.com you not only get a
free gift of meat worth up to $480 but
you also get $15 off with code Walsh the
only big deal your grocery store has is
on expiring Foods so ditch the meat
aisle and subscribe at goodranchers.com
today claim your year of free meat $15
off in free shipping with my code Walsh
atg goodranchers.com goodranchers is the
number one place to get all American
Beef Pork Chicken and Seafood that's
promo code Walsh at goodranchers.com
goodranchers American Meat
delivered so nobody involved in the
Marvels actually said to themselves oh
man this is a story I just have to tell
nobody said that whoever wrote the
script wasn't saying like didn't feel as
they were writing and you could tell
like when you watch when I say lifeless
that's what I mean by lifeless that you
could tell there's no artistic passion
from anyone involved in this thing
including the people who wrote it the
person who wrote it whoever wrote the
Marvels or multiple people who wrote it
they were just it's like they're
punching in 9 to5 and they were they
were told to write this thing because
it's a brand and they want to make and
so they wrote it and they they they
don't they don't care about it they just
wrote it they made money and that's
it
um and I'm not saying that every movie
has to be has to be Paul Thomas Anderson
I'm not saying every movie has to be
like deeply
artistically uh brilliant you can have
movies that are just fun but even fun
movies to be actually fun that it they
have to Value the story that they're
telling and if nobody cares about the
story then it is going to be boring and
lifeless no matter how many fancy
special effects they put on the screen
so that is why I at least am gloating
over this and then on top of the
wokeness and the political correctness
and everything else to me that's like
secondary to this greater problem hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there